I finally played the new smash brothers
the other day and well it felt very
familiar their new characters sure but
the average person would have a tough
time separating it from the previous
games I can already hear people getting
angry that I would say such a thing but
it's true I don't think it's a bad thing
smash brothers is what it is a Nintendo
would be crazy to change things here are
a few reasons why we shouldn't be mad
that we're getting more of the same
you know what's happened since brawl
came out I got hired by gamespot and met
my wife Oh an America elected a black
president the world has changed you know
what hasn't changed our tastes in fun
smash brothers is a great formula the
people have been waiting desperately for
another game have been growing hungrier
and hungrier for that sweet Donkey Kong
fury and who knows how many new people
have opened their eyes to gaming's
goodness of course Nintendo is going to
reuse this dormant formula they've been
letting the hype slowly build for half a
decade
remember PlayStation all-stars battle
royale or Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
smash up how about Onimusha blade
warriors about under and member of these
all these games tried to mimic smash
brothers and all were failures yet may
seem easy enough to make a smash clone
but apparently it's a lot trickier than
it looks so if you want smash brothers
you have to go to the source can you
imagine if Nintendo turn their back on
their fan base change the formula for no
good reason then there won't be any
confident mascot fighters out there we'd
be importing copies of dream mix TV
world fighters and wondering what's
happened to our lives when I play Smash
Brothers it's on those crazy stages with
environmental hazards everywhere with
more weapons than a paranoid militia I'm
casual and proud of it so people like me
we don't even know anything about
balance we just tell our buddy to stop
being curvy because he's a cheap jerk
and get on with the fun but those
competitive players the ones who are
competing it evo for the championship
belt they need perfect balance so by
recycling the same old formula Nintendo
can focus on making the game as perfect
as possible instead of pushing out an
innovative but kind of broken mess that
no one wants to play
mele was an evil last weekend you know
it wasn't wrong the hardcore community
cakes that day Nintendo mess with what
made me late great and destroyed it to
peel I mean seriously he thought
everything would be a good idea being
annoyed by changes isn't only for the
diehards though I'm sure I wasn't alone
when Mewtwo and dr. Mario weren't in
brawl even seemingly small tweaks like
these are met with anger so the asinine
if Nintendo decided to make smash of
Power Stone clone or something you know
what Nintendo is a company that wants to
make money and the quickest way to do
that is to make another smash game
that's just like the last one that's
what people want now there are laps
players like me who are as interested in
the series anymore Nintendo has decided
to cut us loose but that's fine why
change everything to rope in those who
might not even care cater your fan base
and everything will work out swimmingly
now please include warts so everyone can
be happy
you